and she discovered something about me
I'm not a guy of many words right
something that we would have deemed an
unfortunate situation that was kind of a
pain out of that came a blessing
it wasn't until like a year ago when a
lot of just stuff just hit me all at
once and people started reaching out to
me it was like every day God would put
somebody in my path that I don't even
know would reach out to me and said hey
I just want you to know me and my wife
prayed for you this morning whoa like
what that did to me those simple words
if I'm a dad and and I don't even know
what's going on with my 13 year old
daughter I don't even know she's
bleeding out trying to give her water
and food you know God's word let's sit
down and have family worship or whatever
and she's messed up from something
that's gone on at school or who knows so
we've got to deal with the pains and the
hurts first in this Jesus way try it
so we want to talk about Men's Ministry
today if you're not involved in a
Ministry and you are a man this show
here today is for you we've brought
Marty Miller from blueprint for men
thank you for coming on our show today
my privilege
how important is it to be involved in
Men's Ministry you guys involved in a
Men's Ministry at all there's a little
like a Men's Ministry yeah I guess we're
kind of mostly men so
and that's really you know
dealing with topics that we need to to
band together and have some help for so
Marty just give us a little little
blueprint for men background here yeah
sure
um number one I I would like to in this
conversation even though that we have
maybe the title of blueprint for men
Men's Ministry uh quite honestly
men don't the idea of a man being
ministered to
is a negative men don't want to admit
that they've got weaknesses and they've
got problems so I like to say it's just
really a Ministry
but that's not part of the the title we
want to really use it's more about
Band of Brothers men coming together to
engage in a fight that is worth fighting
for you can't win this fight alone you
can't no you can't and and the churches
that I've been to that have a strong
Men's Ministry or just some activities
for men to go out and sharpen each other
you know seem to thrive very well and uh
yeah there are other places too where
um other countries that that the men are
the majority or the minority in the
church the women way outnumber the men
so I think this is important yeah well
we know I think that inherently any of
us that have been part of the church for
a long time we have this knowledge or
idea that we're supposed to be spiritual
leaders but most men have never really
seen it done well and so there's this
directive to do something and a lot of
just silence on how to do that in women
inherently take the lead in the home and
that's really one of the biggest things
going on historic quickly a man knew his
role a woman knew her role there's a lot
of gender and role confusion and so that
plays into a lot of what's going on but
men want to succeed and if they don't
have information and they don't have
guidance
to succeed they are reluctant to lead
interesting and you see that playing out
in our church today I mean there's a
real reason why I believe there's a you
know some real strong pulls away from
you know men is leading and and you know
it's like yeah the women are stepping up
and filling places is that perhaps
because the men aren't fulfilling those
roles like they should or what well I
think that um where does a man find his
identity it's out there
you know it's his work a woman finds her
identity historically and I think it's
still fairly true most women find their
greatest identity in the home with their
children and I know that may be a
stereotype and there may be some women
that would be resistant to hear that but
they're the population at large still
holds that out to be true and so a man
he gets the workplace environment what I
need to do he's got you know his his
calendar all planned out he's got his
budgets he's managing people he's doing
a lot of stuff but he comes home and he
chills he he kind of has the idea I go
home and that's just where I go to my
man cave and I kind of become this
passive
individual not realizing the most
Eternal thing he could do is in this
other locale you've got to win in the
work and at home to be a successful man
your legacy is going to be mostly played
out from your children and so if you
don't get that right it really is mostly
evident as the children get older and as
you get older like right now I'll just
tell you I've got four grandchildren you
guys are at a place in life where I just
go man I wish I could dial it back to
that time I would have made some
adjustments so um yeah I feel like at my
stage of life I'm able to look back
and see things a little clearer
you know many of my friends and other
people I know that are in my age segment
there's either a lot of joy
or a lot of sadness yeah and so we want
men at a young age to have a a plan for
their life every year
what would happen if men at the end of
every year were to sit down and to say
you know I'm going to make a list with
my wife maybe even by himself
but make a list of all the good things
that happened during the year
and and say thank you Lord for that and
sharing it with his family kind of
walking through how God is blessed and
then also to lay out a plan for the next
year work with his wife on that or maybe
just by himself depends on the you know
maybe a single but nevertheless when we
get into that planning mode we focus and
as men our greatest strength
is in our focus and that's what I find
guys get excited about is get them into
a focused plan let me just tell a little
Side Story
um
don't remember the name of the Indian
tribe but they were in the plains and
they had a buffalo hide
okay and they would roll it up
have it rolled up all year and at the
end of the year they would unroll it and
it was a history of their tribe
every year they would write down one
pictograph of what happened
during that one year that was the big
story and so every year in the fall when
they would roll that thing out there
might be a hundred years or more of just
pictographs and the Elder of the tribe
would actually go through all the years
it might take them several days to tell
all the stories of the tribe and then
all of them collectively
would decide what's going this year
interesting and so they they had this
oral tradition
and and in the old days the storytellers
had the greatest esteem in society and
really what you know you guys do here
with LED light you're analyzing story
there's there's this big overarching
story and I think if men could do a
better job at just owning that piece of
reflecting on the blessings
acknowledging the challenges but looking
forward with great hope and optimism and
that way you can lead but if you're
reacting
you don't do well men do not do well
reacting we're not smart enough so
anyway that's kind of what I see is to
be uh some really key pieces with men is
to do better at really having a vision
for their own life but especially for
their family
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in five minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subscribe to
video bible study on YouTube to help you
along your journey
I remember reading a a book that um a
nurse had written and she was worked in
hospice she constantly saw people die
and she wrote down there was these
common things that kept coming up all
the time when men would die and the
number one thing was like why did I work
so hard why didn't I spend more time
with the loved ones that I had and you
know that there were some things like
that and I think it's it's good if
you're not self-reflecting on on that
how did this last year go what can I
make an adjustment for the next year and
kind of fostering that you know constant
adjustment yeah and I think that a
fallacy that most guys in their mind are
thinking
I'm in this slog to get my kids to
adulthood you know there's there's just
a lot of it's a major effort to launch
young people successfully
but
even beyond that they're still your kids
I've got a 35 year old son and a 32 year
old daughter and I am always you know in
the morning when I'm having my quiet
time and I'm just kind of thinking about
my day I try to go okay
how are my relationships that inner
circle what am I doing uh so you know
this morning I haven't talked to my
daughter in a while she's busy in her
own world and and I just thought man I
haven't really talked to my daughter in
quite a while been weeks and so you know
I put on my notation for the day is I'm
going to reach out to my daughter and I
I think that that kind of intentionality
again needs to start when they're young
but it never ends and
really what you will find if you do that
I believe this because I've seen it
happen is that your children
in best case scenario will become your
friends
and there's nothing more beautiful than
that you know um I remember when I was
teaching high school you know I was well
loved by my students I had a good
relationship
but with my own kids during those years
it was tough so I I mean you guys are in
the throes of it I know kind of the age
segment that you're dealing with and uh
it could be rough but don't quit just
stay engaged
um Embrace and hug the porcupine so it's
really neat I got a chance to go to one
of his blueprint for men's
Retreats and um to see a room full I
don't remember how many people were
there maybe 200 300 yeah a little over
100. so there's a lot and to see these
little groups of men praying and and
interacting with each other is just not
something you typically see a lot of
that and I was really blessed by what
happened it was very practical
information we went over lots of
different subjects things that you know
men struggle with and you know just just
talking it out and some of the
activities that they had at the table
were were really just getting us to you
know verbalize with each other some
things some challenges some things that
we've overcome or whatever you know and
and I remember leaving that weekend and
just being like man I think every church
needs to experience this for your
therapeutic I went to a big conference
it was a men's thing and it was it was
it was really powerful to see a whole
room full of men singing at the top of
their lungs some music together and
stuff and and hearing good messages I
think it's definitely beneficial mm-hmm
So speaking to that you know what let me
just explain in in my world with with
Men's Ministry a ministry that's kind of
gone all over the place worldwide we
think of it as a funnel and you guys do
the same thing with with what you're
doing you've got the upper end which is
communication and information people can
access on a you know just from anywhere
then you have the next layer which of
these events you're talking about Okay
so we've got a gathering of men it could
be 20 guys could be 100 guys could be a
thousand it doesn't really matter it's a
large Gathering of guys that again
you're getting into the water a little
bit you know your toes are getting wet
you're having to engage you're in
conversations
um you feel something
and then the next layer that we find is
really when you get you know you're
starting to get immersed is a small
group and a small group
um like my son he's he's very busy
um he's 35 like I said he's got four
little girls and every other week he
gets to gather with a group of his
friends guys that are in the same age
bracket raising families and they get
together every other week at a coffee
shop and just kind of they have uh
a particular word they're focusing on
and maybe a scripture just keeping it
real simple but checking in on areas
where they feel like they need to grow
and so it's half the time is just kind
of checking in how's it going in your
world how can we pray for you here's our
our word for the day and how can we
Embrace that like it might be Integrity
or something like that but it's just a
touch Point once a week for an hour at
this coffee shop at six a.m that's the
only time these guys have
and that is a real strength to that
demographic is what I find it's just
being intentional but that's that small
group level we have small groups that
have met for years and go through just
continual different books and video
series and stuff like that and it's
those groups tend to be a little bit
older demographic my age you know guys
that are in their 50s and older kids are
out of the house and they just find this
is meeting a need for them
but there's this other layer that the
retreat you came to most recently was
really about how to take it to the
deepest level and that's more on that
one-on-one okay I reach out to you Mikey
and I go hey let's do lunch sometime I
want to hear how things are going in
your life you know you you shared
something with me and I just want to
follow up you got some time you're still
eating lunch yeah you know and what guy
isn't gonna go for free lunch right you
know wherever you want uh so anyway you
go out to eat and you just ask questions
as an older man you're just saying hey I
want to hear about what's going on in
your life you know I I care about you
and that means a lot I mean how many
times in your life
as a man where you're at
30s and 40s
does that happen it's rare I don't think
it's ever happened to me yeah actually
and I tell these guys that are older I
said you need to initiate you've got the
probably a little bit more discretionary
money and and schedule you reach out to
these young men and I and I will do that
at Retreats or any Gathering and say
just do this one thing
and God's going to prompt you right now
who is that one man that's awesome and
take action don't don't say well yeah I
should no write it down right now I am
going to take
Jim yeah out to lunch and and then after
they've been able to eat have this good
dopamine trickle you know from some good
food talking you say Hey you know I I
appreciate you sharing with me and do
you mind if I just pray with you I mean
even if a young man is not really
connected in faith activities at that
point in his life
just the very fact that you care yeah
and yeah they're not going to say no
right but speak volumes yeah and it's
really a prayer of affirmation and love
and care and I want to share with you
guys
a prayer that I have found to be so good
because the hand is such a great
teaching tool I don't know if I've
shared this with you but the hand is uh
used a lot of times in team building
okay
so in team building if you have a group
the one thing you want to encourage one
another so that's thumbs up
and then you're going to take Direction
and sometimes correction there's going
to be no negative talk so the Zinger
finger we want to keep that down with
the thumb of encouragement and the ring
finger is we're not going to quit on
each other we're going to keep going and
we're going to you know give it our best
and the pinky is one of us is going to
have some kind of weakness going to be
the weak link here in this team
initiative and and yet we Embrace that
because together we're going to be
stronger just like that pinky when we
bring it in we've got more strength so
taking that for my days and working in
outdoor leadership and team building I
have felt God give me that as a tool for
guys to pray
for their spouse for their children to
another young man
and it just goes like this
put your art you know hand on a young
man's shoulder or your wife it doesn't
matter
and what you start out with is it's like
you're bringing God right into this
prayer and all you got to do is say God
thank you so much for making Mikey I
just I see so many good qualities enlist
those qualities I see a man of integrity
I see hard-working man he's got a heart
for for you and a heart for others and I
want him to know that you love him so
much you saw him before he was born and
you have a plan for his life and and and
I see that in him and I want him to know
that and and also I Lord I want you to
to speak to him today
and that he will follow your voice you
follow your lead
and then he will have the humility
sometimes when it might be somebody else
that's telling the direction that he
will humbly Embrace that as well and be
teachable
and then the the Zinger finger is to say
and I know that Mikey's going to go
through
a tough time he might be going through
it you might have shared with me at the
time you know the enemies come against
him
but I want him to know that
you love him
I know I care for him
and that he's going to be strong enough
to overcome this help him to cling to
your word and then also the ring finger
would be
help him to know that you're never going
to leave him or forsake Him I'm going to
be him for him and that uh just to
encourage him not to ever quit just keep
on down this path and that whatever
weakness that he might have shared as
well or my wife might have shared is is
going to be an opportunity for God your
power to be manifest in his life and
that through that he's going to have a
testimony and and when you pray that
kind of a prayer it just brings it all
together with whatever the good stuff
the struggles the the community with God
this other person
um I've just seen it as such a good tool
because we have our hand and so just
something simple and practical
that I can't stress enough
many times we pray with somebody
rarely do we pray for them and if we do
we flesh it out in a way that actually
turns it into a blessing people are
hungry for a blessing most men never got
it from their father
um from any man and if you as a man as
an older man step in
then it's it's a hunger in the soul of
most men and women one other little side
note my wife she works with women
and many of the women she works with
spiritual counseling stuff you know the
the Brokenness and the the things that
bitterness that they're hanging on to
and she helps them to break through that
to let it go so they can have freedom
one of the biggest needs with these
young women is that and and they may be
older women
um is they never heard that they were
loved that they were valued that they
were treasured and so we have this
little script
that she reads and I repeat and I'm
standing like this close
to this woman and for me to speak the
words because her father never did and
he's dead or will never speak those
words
um
just the tears yeah it's just it's it's
just unbelievable it's the hunger yeah
of every man and woman's Soul there's a
real practical side of the Gospel that I
think that that's what I'm hearing this
is kind of fostering I mean information
is great I love learning about the Bible
we sit around I mean we we've often
thought about just turning a camera on
to our little worships that we have in
the morning because it's just great
conversation that comes out of it but
there's really the where's where does
this information meet the actual
experience and I think that's where you
know getting involved in a small group
or having a mentor or even being a
mentor for somebody else you get the
chance to see the gospel at work exactly
it's amazing what your kids teach you
um
you know we have we have four and so
we've noticed you know similarities
between two like usually the ones on
either end the oldest and the youngest
they have a lot of similarities and the
two in the middle have a lot of
similarities
and
um I I don't say this to like fault
you know what I'm about to say like
because I know she's watching
um my mom never said I love you a lot
when I was growing up
um it's not that I didn't know or if she
did I don't remember so I mean there's
there's always that too I don't remember
hearing that a lot my dad was better
better about it
um but my I didn't really hear that a
lot from my mom and so
myself naturally I'm not inclined to
express that to even my own children as
much as I might think about it
but I have my my two middle children
they're very much geared that way and
like you know it's it's amazing like if
I'm leaving for the day or if I'm
putting them to bed
I'm like I'm always getting that
especially my my son Isaac he's like the
middle boy he's like you know he's
always telling me he loves me he's the
initiator in that he's really good about
it and it helps remind me that yes I do
need to be expressing those those words
and sensitivity
um so it's amazing what your kids can
teach you and
funny story too it's kind of a side note
yeah
um
we got a treadmill for our house because
it's colder here in the winter and you
don't always want to walk outside and
it's just easier you know there's no
track to go to anything like that
so I've got a treadmill and we my wife
and I have been using it you know we'd
alternate you know one goes first the
other room goes last in the morning and
get up early and do that so we
um you know or making sure we're taking
care of our health in that regard
and we had a situation in our basement
so we had to take care of some couple of
vermin and my wife did not want to go
down to the basement whatsoever you know
I was just like totally off limits so I
had to take care of some some issues
well in the meantime she was like you
know one morning she wanted to go walk
she's she's lifting and she's doing all
these things to take care of herself and
she's like will you go with me you know
to walk outside
you know he's like sure you know I'm not
going to make a big deal about it you
know we don't typically go because
there's cars on the road and don't want
to deal with that but we went
you know since that day we've been going
every day and she discovered something
about me so maybe this is for you too
I'm not a guy of many words right but
she found when you get me up in the
morning I'm a lot more talkative early
in the morning interesting and I'm like
getting getting my words out and so then
it didn't matter if the problem was gone
in the basement
you know that was taken care of she
still wanted to go outside and walk
because I was talking to her in the
morning and so by you know something
that we would have deemed a an
unfortunate situation that was kind of a
pain out of that came a blessing and
beautiful uh yeah something something
beautiful so we're not walking on the
treadmill anymore I'm like maybe we
should just sell the thing you know and
it's it started in more or less in the
winter and it wasn't that it's not that
bad you can't go every morning you know
it doesn't always work but it's
certainly been helpful to us and and a
good a good time together so yeah guys
when you've been married as long as my
wife and I have you'll have it all
figured out just kidding
I I go I've been I learned so slowly
there's a lot of things that I like the
reminder though about about the the
young men I've I've tried to do that and
I've I've actually gotten off track of
it so I'm glad you brought this up again
yeah we'll have these guys that come
into our church that are interning for
to be pastors
and you know the pastor is really their
mentor and the one that's this you know
but we encourage the elders to also do
that as well to Mentor them you know
they're acting in in a pastoral role as
well I was used to take every extern
that we had I used to take him to lunch
and set them down it's because these
guys are like half my age now and I'm
like man this is so weird like you're
about to be a pastor of an entire
congregation feels like yeah it feels
like you're not ready for that but I
know I know it's not it's not just them
I mean they're they're to be guided and
led by the Holy Spirit and there's
there's no substitute for that kind of
you know
um you know I'm I'm not a match for the
Holy Spirit but certainly I can I can
speak to your experience and things that
I've learned and encourage them you know
to do what they're doing and go the
right way but I need to get on that
again yeah it's such an easy thing to do
it is an easy thing and it's so god-led
you know you don't have to have a script
I think one of the things that most guys
do is they go well I don't know what is
I don't even know what I'd say
but I think the Bible makes a promise
you know maybe more in a more uh scary
way you know when you're called to stand
and get testify maybe in a judgment or
whatever you're don't worry about it I'm
going to give you what to say but I
think that in a sense we dial it back
isn't that what we're feeling as a
judgment you know somebody's gonna think
I'm too critical or I don't know what to
say I'm not eloquent or my life's not
all together what a you know what can I
tell them you know and we discredit
ourselves
um Mikey I don't know if you have any
anything I was just thinking about what
you what you're talking about is is just
a simple thing and I my life has been
pretty
easy going I mean I I've
never had like a hard childhood I've
always like had friends like I've never
experienced like loneliness depression
and all those types of things
so
it wasn't until like a year ago when a
lot of just stuff just hit me all at
once and and people started reaching out
to me it was like every day God would
put somebody in my path whether it's on
messenger text message it'd be somebody
random somebody from Florida somebody
from Georgia somebody that you know that
I don't even know but watches the show
or something
would reach out to me and said hey I
just want you to know me and my wife
prayed for you this morning and like
whoa like what that did to me those
simple words me and my wife prayed for
you this morning I was like Wow
somebody's actually taking time because
I know prayer works I know there's power
in it and to know that people are
actually doing it because I think so
often we tell people I'll be praying for
you brother
how often does it really happen I think
sometimes we say it almost like good
luck or you know we we say it because we
do have good intentions like I'll be
praying for you but does it actually
really happen are you on your knees
saying Lord I'm praying for Scotty for
that thing or are you just saying I'll
be praying for you and maybe putting
some emojis some praying emojis on a
post but not really doing it and so when
I but when you say this morning we
actually did it that proves to me that
it's happening and so that caught
because I realized how much that meant
to me I took intention to tell people
that initiative to tell people that like
I would tell people yeah I'm praying for
you but then I would actually go out of
my way to message them and say hey I
pray for you this morning or even press
the record button and literally pray to
them on there there you go it's three to
five minutes of your time that you're
actually letting that person know that
the prayer is happening and uh it really
is such a simple thing that that we
don't realize the impact it has I didn't
realize until a year ago how much impact
it has we're becoming really fragmented
as a society you know and we talk about
this in in our Social Media stuff and
how it's like it's supposed to draw us
together but it's really pushing us
further apart and there's many times
where I've sat and thought you know you
get that idea it's like nobody cares you
know people don't just necessarily reach
out to you and it's a difficult step to
take and say well it doesn't matter if
anybody's reaching out to me I'm going
to reach out to somebody else you know
and when you do that
you're you know if if you're following
that prompting from God
you know you're you're doing it to bless
somebody else
but it really does something for you
yeah as well and not not that you do it
so that you feel good about yourself but
there there is a blessing in that and I
find it's not just that way with friends
I mean his family can be that way it's
it's you know it can be frustrating you
can you can think you're the only one in
your family that reaches out to other
family you know like
my bless his heart you know you're in
the South you can say that about people
right my grandpa will never call me
never
he's just that way you think I'm quiet
he's like 10 times quieter than I am he
doesn't
call hmm I don't know why if I want to
talk to him I call him you know and I
realized after I got older after I got
up you know my 18 20 years old like if I
wanted to have a relationship with my
grandpa I had to reach out to him and
call him and I've built a relationship
with my grandpa like I know him better
than you know I did as a kid but my fear
was as a kid like I'm gonna not ever
know this guy he lives in another state
we don't talk he's never going to call
me
hmm if I want that I have to go and seek
it out and it's it's been good you know
I've there's been times I've had to ask
him some some difficult questions and
you know he gave me an answer but
sometimes you just got to take the step
even though you don't think anybody else
is taking the step yeah I think as men
you you feel like you know I should have
this all figured out right and and the
the hardest thing that I feel like is
reaction Kobe did it I hate asking for
directions like
that for GPS yeah it drives my wife
crazy and I'm just like no I know where
I'm going and she's just like what
that's why I bought a smartphone yeah
literally saved our marriage yeah
but but I think that that that that
struggle of just you know wanting to
hold up this success flag you know and
it's like you'd you we're not like that
we're all in need of help and you know I
think that that realization that you're
just coming to the table and just saying
look guys I'm really struggling in this
area and I need some help the
encouragement that you could be to
someone else right you know and or you
know that you need that kind of
encouragement you know it's I think it's
valuable it's like witnessing though you
know when when you witness to somebody
um you're going to be filled when you
share yeah right right it's just a
principle of the Kingdom so when you
encourage you're going to be encouraged
it's just it's a natural outflow of the
way God has designed it yeah well you
know there's there's one of my favorite
quotes uh from from Ellen White that
basically says that in all of nature we
see this flow of energy and matter I'm
paraphrasing except for the selfish
heart of man that's the universal
principle it has to flow and so when we
can get position ourselves
with God yeah in the flow into that flow
and we're part of that that's where Joy
comes from it's like if you want to be
happy and joyful
find ways to make other people happy and
joyful and you will you take somebody
that's depressed
and you take them to maybe on a mission
project or down to the soup kitchen
anything you know where you're helping
somebody and you your eyes are off
yourself and and it's the antidote
um
yeah I know there's real depression and
all those kind of things but I think
that
it is exacerbated by the culture we live
in you know that's inward so what kind
of like activities do you do with
blueprint for men I know you guys have
taken some pretty extreme things you
have a worldwide Ministry yeah so what
what what is it that you're actually
trying to do and achieve
well it always comes down to the
individual okay so uh for me just
recently I had an epiphany that I'll
share with you and I think that you guys
being in a Ministry can understand this
but um I was at the uh a big convention
and um this guy was talking about the um
in his sermon he was talking about uh
the man being healed of the pool of
Bethesda and he was saying this man was
trying to get into this pool of water
and he didn't have anybody to help him
get there he wanted that was his excuse
I can't get in here I don't have anybody
to get me here and Jesus basically said
well I'm right here do you want to do
you want to get well and he kind of
called him out on it you know it's like
all right you could wait hadn't been
working out you've been here 38 years
and so he took that step of faith and of
course he got up and we knocked walked
and we know that story well
the thing that I like to take away from
that is that sometimes
if you're in Ministry you're trying to
uh
get to certain people to leverage what
you're trying to do for your ministry
Church organizational structure key
people if we can get that guy or this
person to be to financially support you
know then then things are going to come
together for us in this in this whole
new way and and that story there
reminded me it hit me like a ton of
bricks that don't look to other people
To Be Your solution I'm right here to
Jesus and and I think that's a real
reminder so in my journey with trying to
get to this large audience of men
um but within the context of the church
because I still value the church
um the church I think is going to come
back to its roots
and I think a big part of coming back to
its roots like the early church is
meeting around tables
um and it starts with men having the
confidence
to lead their families it's got to start
there we see this is the greatest uh
effort of the enemy to destroy the
family the marriages and families and
it's just the ripple effect is just
catastrophic and we all know it we've
experienced it maybe personally
but nevertheless what can we do where
we're at as men to say no further you
know not in my house now I have a
a simple little Sharpie illustration
here I don't know if you guys can see it
on the screen here but the the Paleo
Hebrew
picture
for the letter B which is pronounced bet
like Bethlehem
bet means house and the letter B looked
like this it's a footprint of a nomadic
tent okay so I added these people in
here they understand to illustrate my
point here but when a
tent was set up it kind of went around
like this the way I understand it and
the father was the one that laid right
there
at the door yeah Over My Dead Body
you've heard of that right and so
inherently by very definition a man knew
that he was a protector the physical
protector of his wife and his children
nobody was going to get to them unless
it was over his dead body literally now
I think that most guys even today would
Embrace that that are that are any kind
of a man they're trying to be a good
husband and father
but we we don't see the invisible and
this is where I want to challenge Ben
and I find that this is really uh it's
we we hear in the church from the time
we're little that Jesus loves me and
that's true and we we can't really
understand totally even what that simple
phrase means
but what I want to say is this there's
an invisible enemy out there that your
ministry is devoted to exposing
that young men and old men alike we all
need to have our eyes opened to
understand that spiritually if we are
not on guard
we we've we've left that opening for the
enemy to come in to our wife and to our
children
and for me it was in like being a
workaholic you know just too consumed
with work and I think that this is again
back to what I was saying most men find
their identity out here they spend a lot
of time out here just crumbs with their
family
but when it comes to the spiritual
particularly if a man is not finding
time daily to spend time with God
and to lead his family in the spiritual
path
he's leaving the door wide open and when
we see what's going on with the children
and in marriages I just
you know to remind guys and I have to
remind myself we
are responsible
so if I am not spiritually on guard and
and protective and aware
I'm leaving that door open for the enemy
to get there and I know I've seen that
damage in my own home because I was
asleep in that area so just a reminder
in a very simple picture
this is the home
and we are the protectors does that pass
kind of uh sleep drive you to teach men
where they're at now yeah it's out of
you have to have that Warrior
has to come up yeah
you have to have an anger towards the
enemy
the love of Jesus was not enough for me
I'm just saying where where I was at
that particular time in my life where I
just came to that fork in the road and I
said
no more I'm making changes and it was
through my experience in small group in
a Men's Ministry when I came and I
started seeing myself and seeing God's
love in a new way from
a man's perspective that resonated with
me
I I finally addressed certain things in
my life that changed everything and
that's really the reason for this
ministry to get those Concepts earlier
on I think is is a great you know reason
to get involved in in Men's Ministry so
that we don't we don't get to the end of
our life when we're tired and we're out
of energy and it's like oh look at all
of us have messed up right and and I
think um you know a real practical way
of diving in laying out on the table
here's here's what's going on and having
some accountability having some you know
inspiration and those kind of things
like what does it mean to be a real
Christ follower and a man right what
does that mean right and and in the
church I I I think that the churches
that I visited that had a very very
strong presence of male
um you know they were engaged and
involved in church seemed to thrive and
and you know a lot of times I I help out
with the with the little kids programs a
lot in my church and a lot of times
who's there it's the women you know
there aren't a lot of men that are are
leading those little the groups and
stuff and so um you know I think it's
really neat that what you're doing is
really inspiring them and and I like
that you know uh daddy daughter camp out
trips and stuff that you do I think
that's a really important aspect too if
you have a daughter the male is a huge
thing in her world right so let me ask a
real practical question here put you
guys on the spot a little bit you guys
have teenage kids have you
and my answer would have been no so I'm
just telling you I I you know my kids
are grown but do you have a anything
written down a plan
on how to be the dad
that your teenage daughter needs
whatever you know your son needs at this
stage of his life are you there's
there's five kinds of dads one is the
the totally gone dad you know never been
involved in life for whatever reason all
the way up to the the the the highest
level dad and that is the intentional
father that he's got a plan and he lives
it out he is a blessing to his children
um it's not a passive Endeavor so do you
or have you ever written this is what
I'm going to do this year
and actually put it on the calendar I've
never ever done that I've never written
it out I certainly have talked about it
with with my wife you know she's a great
reminder of you know oh yeah these years
are ticking down I only have a couple
left with my daughter and how old is she
again she's 13. most you know what when
I give this talk I always say this is
interesting I always say what's your
plan for your 13 year old daughter this
year yeah she needs you to be strong yep
she needs to feel your strength in a way
that she understands you see a treasure
in her in val you know I'm sure you do
these things but there are specific
little things that we can do as men that
are really difference makers and if
we're not intentional you will end up
five years down the road going man I
oops Yeah I missed some opportunities
and so that's my greatest uh you know if
I speak to this audience right now some
of you are young men that you're not
even married maybe you are married maybe
you have young children it doesn't
matter where you're at in the spectrum
is be intentional there's so much
information we're living in a world
where there's never been more
information and Light
but whether we're going to plug into it
is another thing it's like you know we
were talking about chat GTP and all this
kind of AI type stuff coming along you
can have all that you want but in the
end you've got data you've got
information you've got knowledge you've
got wisdom
but there's one other step what's the
final step for all of that implication
the application yeah yeah if we're not
applying it in our lives
All Is Lost yeah and so that really is
the challenge for each one of us is how
am I applying how am I making a
difference in the life of my children my
spout you know our marriage
um wherever I go and and uh it's a
sobering thought because we're never
going to be enough to get it all right
you can live this life a hundred times
and you'd still
come up with a lot of deficits so don't
beat yourself too much up but as you
look back say
I'm going to do better this year yeah
I've got this moment 13 year old
daughter yeah man yeah don't miss it
yeah those last few years are going to
tick by so quick so yeah but you put in
a good foundation and I I think you know
that we we love our children but the dad
I'll just say this a dad's role in the
teenage years is huge yeah I'm going to
share a little research with you guys
that's mind-blowing there's three kinds
of families out there there's the mother
and father together
there's a mother raising her children by
herself and there's a man raising his
children by himself
when you look at those three types of
homes and the children that come from
those homes
we would expect that the family that's
intact is going to have the highest
outcome the best outcome and that's true
when we compare a man raising children
by himself and a woman she weighs
raising children by herself
it's actually the man that is able to
pull off more successful children Than a
Woman by herself now there's a lot of
reasons by for that and I admire all
women and men that are trying to do
their best but there's just something
that a man brings during those very
tough teenage years that firmness and
protection and there's just
a different dimension that is so much
needed by our teenage kids and when a
man could bring that
he brings so much goodness
and and I just pray for our our families
because that's where the enemies rotten
to do his destruction I want to share
one last thing and then I'll we'll wrap
it up here but this has to do with
survival
we are in a survival okay this world is
a survival scene and so when you think
about a survival I don't know have you
ever guys ever done a survival training
of any kind yeah no I'd like to I have
it's actually really fun yeah well
anyway in a survival there's there's
kind of a hierarchy there's things that
you address first and then last most
people think of you know we gotta get
water and fire and shelter and all this
kind of stuff but there are several
other layers that are many times
unspoken and the first one is even
before you start to do anything to
respond to a life-and-death disaster uh
where it's survival is you need to stop
before you start you stop and so what
that stands for is sit think observe and
plan Okay so we've got before we do
something let's have a plan
that's that blueprint you know what am I
going to do here well let's think about
it you know let's get some good guidance
uh for that 13 year old daughter
whatever
so you get a plan
and then you got to start acting now in
a group
usually into a disaster or a survival
it's there's multiple people involved
there has to be somebody that takes the
lead hmm
okay so you gotta have leadership
somebody's got to take the lead have the
initiative have some expertise that
they're bringing in strength
after that is actually medical who is
hurt
you know we got to take care of those
physical needs then after that
communication can we get a signal out
let's dial 9-1-1
after that comes shelter
after that fire and then water and food
now I'm going to use that as a framework
for for each one of you guys that are
trying to raise a family
and I'll just use it from the context of
even the church as well anytime you have
a group of people
when you come together
when you look at somebody
I don't know what's going on in your
life you know
and if you're bleeding out
I need to take care of that whatever I
can do or or if I'm a dad and and I
don't even know what's going on with my
13 year old daughter
I don't even know she's bleeding out you
know and and I'm
trying to give her water and food you
know God's word let's sit down and have
family worship or whatever and she's
messed up from something that's gone on
at school or who knows
so we've got to deal with the pains and
the hurts first in this Jesus way this
Jesus way this is not anything we
shouldn't know but deal with pain first
after that shelter and shelter is
boundaries is this a safe place
is what's said here stays here if you're
working in like in a men's group same
thing you know uh and then after the
shelter is fire
and thinking about men you know emotions
am I a smoky fire am I cold
am I over here that I'm like gasoline on
a fire I've got a temper and I'm out you
know outspoken or am I that warm fire
that draws you know we can do a lot with
and then after that you get to the water
and the food which would be you know the
Holy Spirit In God's word if we get that
out of alignment and reversed
I maintain this is the biggest reason
why churches and homes get upside down
and kids don't find that anything to
to draw them we've got to be wise enough
as men
to say Lord help me to see what I can't
see
and to be a force for healing and
goodness yeah Jesus Jesus spent more
time healing yeah I mean you just have
so many examples of appealing and then
naturally your response when you get
those things taken care of is like what
else do you know you know and it's like
you're hungry for it and yeah you're
right I mean if you know a lot of times
if it's just like such an emphasis on
the spiritual but then they're over here
trying to just dog paddle and get a
breath of air in the in the ocean you
know
um it's it's difficult to that at that
point so yeah get them to safety you
know those are some real practical
things that that we don't normally hear
we don't think about it you know it's
just you know pray enough I believe in
prayer powerful powerful tool right we
need all these things working in
conjunction together to bolster up a
strand strong male presence that I
believe is is a the PowerHouse in the
church right I'll share one last thing
that has to do and I think I said last
thing last time but this is this is a
segue from from bringing that uh fresh
bread in in a in a spiritual leadership
because I think the the iconic thing
that most people in the church
have experienced with and know that it's
really important is that family
devotional worship time and it gets
really hard during teenage years it's
crazy
but I I know a guy he had four teenage
girls
you know that's that's tough Zone okay
and so I asked him I said what are you
what are you doing for like family
worship time and he said you know what
my wife and I have been doing that's
really been working is we don't call it
Family Worship anymore
we just say hey let's let's get together
and have a uh kind of a check-in you
know Pow Wow family pow whatever you
want to call it and uh you know the
girls who come together and okay we have
a rule
we're checking in you got to share one
thing that went good today one thing
that maybe not so good that okay so
we're starting with the youngest okay
tell us something that really you know
tell us some details you know what what
went well today so she says whatever it
is anything not goes so well you know
maybe something just totally like well
whatever but still they're sharing and
they're used to this process and the
older girls
and the parents while this is going on
you see the the pain we're dealing with
this is the good stuff but now we've got
a little pain Point here
and every one of the siblings can speak
that yeah I had something happen like
that too and you'll be okay this is what
I did and or this is how it turned out
and there's a little storytelling going
on there and then the parents if they
have this walk with God
um they usually God's going to bring
something to you know that reminds me of
this one verse and and you share that
it's just it's a natural
storytelling that there's this insertion
of encouragement
wisdom from God's word direction and
then by the time you've gone through all
four kids
they have a group prayer and a group hug
and they're done
the Trojan Horse came in
and they had that spiritual
strengthening
[Music]
All in the Family context it's powerful
I can't encourage that enough yeah try
it well Marty Miller has a an awesome
Ministry blueprint for men we'll put a
link in the description below you have a
podcast that is really dealing with a
lot of topics and things that men
struggle with some encouraging podcasts
just some different topical things so
um I encourage you check it out but out
of this conversation I hope that you
guys were blessed um we need to get
involved and as men we're not little
Islands you know it's like get in there
start helping in your church start
mentoring and going up to the younger
generation if you are an older person
like me uh or you know just really find
someone to to just check in with them
and bless them and you will be surprised
to see how God works out of that thank
you Marty for coming by we pray for men
check them out thank you patreon
supporters for so supporting the work
that we do and helping out of course
check out our t-shirts we've got a great
t-shirt Ministry so you can wear your
witness around and maybe start a
conversation that uh you know you
wouldn't have normally been able to
start but somebody noticed something
cool in your T-shirt and uh we hope you
guys are blessed we'll see you next week
this year check out light
it's a Christian owned apparel company
with the belief that we are all walking
the Billboards one of the best ways to
share your witness is to wear your
witness these conversation starter
designs are the perfect way to look good
while shining your light for Christ for
a limited time use promo code love for
15 off your entire order that's 15 off
for new clothing for you and maybe a
gift for someone special so go to
lightwear dot shop and remember use
promo code love
[Music]